what up YouTube this is biz dev Sunday
what you're about to watch is a
Instagram live of us debating our 25 50
and hundred sneaker sets
please watch below and if you are in the
market for twenty five fifty or a
hundred sneakers please email me right
here we'll make up an email maybe a
sneaker barter at vaynermedia comm and
an email with your proposals because
we're about the drop
this week maybe early next week this
whole concept of twenty five and fifty
and a hundred pair of sneakers yo what
up in swim live we're in a meeting right
now and I decided to make you guys a
part of it so and Edie Rock and Tyler
and I are here and we are contemplating
something super cool when I launched my
books I launched these really cool packs
so bunch of you've taken me up on the
buy ten sneakers right buy ten of these
and you get a surprise and that's gonna
be fresh as [ __ ] everybody who took care
of that on Facebook two days ago you
guys heard of love it Jim quick what's
up man
oh yes Jim thank you so much that last
post by the way that's right well I've
got 2,000 of you real quick that last
post the post I have right now on on
Instagram is the most emotional post
I've ever put out in the history of my
life period
it is a woman coming up to me telling me
that my content stopped her from suicide
and so super heady as you can imagine on
a far less serious note before I go into
my next meeting which is now running 36
minutes late someone [ __ ] on those
clowns Paris she didn't need this
certificate because it was a gun license
I actually have it here give me to you
right I have it on my wall really what's
that it's gonna need
anyway this is her actually the front I
can show I don't maybe I don't want to
show the plate I don't know nonetheless
there is it she doesn't need it because
she doesn't want to have a gun anymore
because she doesn't what to take her
life it was super handy anyway um I want
to lighten up the mood here for a minute
and go a little bit more on the
entrepreneurial side when I launched my
books I always do these packs where if
you buy ten books or 25 books or 50
books or a hundred books you get X so
we're sitting here contemplating one of
this really cool push for the second
wave for the sneaker right and we want
to do a 25 of fifty and a hundred pack
and we're kind of deciding like you know
what that's gonna be
right what's that good and I want to get
your guys thoughts so if you wanted DM
me or tweet actually tweet twit by the
way if you're not following me on
Twitter you're making a huge mistake it
is a hundred percent where I'm mostly
I've engaged on Twitter every day my
life for last decade eleven years like
I'm so cozy with it it's so much easier
I mean and the comments section in here
is pretty fresh but like oh I don't need
to clean my camera lens it's just
delighting the same see so wasn't the
lens it was just the lighting so anyway
the the the reality is that we're
putting together two packs and I thought
it would be super duper cool if you guys
gave recommendations on what I should
fill the packs with so like in essence
you get 25 pairs that's 2,500 bucks
5,000 and 10,000 what should the
packages be because I'm gonna launch a
site in a week where if you buy 25 pairs
you you send in the receipt and you get
X and unlike the stuff I've been around
social media where it's just random what
up Malika Jefferson Jefferson man a dog
like loved him come out of
Malik knows what I think about his game
I wanted him to be a banner sports guy
and I wanted him to be in New York jet
I got neither but that's all right Malik
wishing health health health baby do
your thing
anyway would love ideas from the
community on 25 50 and hundred ba
sneaker orders what would you want in in
return what's different about these
landing pages when I do what I do is you
know what you get so the key is you know
it's twenty five hundred five thousand
and ten thousand dollars I don't play
around a hundred dollars to buy a pair
of sneakers blows me away I don't expect
anybody buy anything zero key you know
just keep watching content and live
yours but I'm hustling I'm trying to win
and I'm trying to do cool stuff so like
for example I think let's just
brainstorm it right here with these
people like a closet what's that
we have we have a closet dirt yeah
that's what's up yeah really yeah down
the dm1 all right brainstorming I think
if you think about it here's what I love
about 25 50 100
I think the hundred should be like a fit
we gotta figure out like what are we
since my time like a hundred thousand or
fifty like 100 if I travel it's 150
correct but what about like is a 50 an
hour that we planed under the impression
I think if somebody buys up so you know
we'll buy a fuckload of 100 pairs
companies and then I could come in and
get maybe a 50 meter scale the people
the promised [ __ ] it's only ten
thousand bucks like what am I gonna do
500 pairs and I'll come and Skype your
company for a minute what ooh
people can come here for these is ten
thousand dollars
Oh Annie sneakers for ten thousand yeah
so you get a hunt I you know what I'll
probably do a trade for the four DS like
one day only yeah like a one day okay
let's do a separate campaign that we do
on first in line and email announce it
ahead of time all have you been wanting
to buy four DS we're gonna do a one-day
where if you buy a hundred pairs which
is ten thousand bucks you get a four DS
for free so in essence you're getting
twenty thousand bucks for 10,000 bucks
ago okay that's definitely yeah but on a
separate landing page at Sam's building
right now 25 50 100 companies will buy a
hundred they'll give it to employees
what and onto the rail organizations
would I give a 10-minute we can also
sell them out we can maximize it you
know like okay if I give a 10-minute
talk or a 15-minute Q&A because 15
minutes feels like the minimum wise your
dick right
and I'll never do tell you come on feel
bad yeah all right 15 minutes no 10,000
its 40,000 it's not a good deal but
about a thousand I guess I could do 10
of us actually let's look in here yo
what's up let me can you somebody read
the comments cuz can look you go on
desktop can you on desktop live no no
desktop live yet your Instagram you need
a desktop live alright what do people
say this is some smart because you can
either yeah I mean you know
my lammie dairy she nailed it the thing
if people are smart if you do five
minutes here's the thing if you're
[ __ ] smart you can keep the [ __ ] out
of this because you can go on eBay and
do $79.99 buy it now yeah and basically
only pay 2,000 bucks I just felt really
you know what am I should level up my
game from dailyvee to the live stream
24/7 like old justin.tv live e people
get real people have gotten really smart
from dailyvee and made money if I
[ __ ] went live V people be
trillionaires out of this [ __ ]
do they know I'm available
Oh 43 minutes alright what's going on
here
that's not Neymar on the wall me and
that's the [ __ ] real go Pele baby
Pele they are all right I might need
five minutes down right in their [ __ ]
mouth Ethan Bradberry what up please
check out my latest post everybody who's
positive and excited out there you
absolutely need to keep spreading
positivity the world needs us the world
needs you please give it please give it
alright what is going on um do they
laugh do they know that I meant [ __ ]
them yes um want recommendations hit me
up on Twitter for twenty five fifty and
a hundred pairs sneaker combos we're
launching the website
[Music]
Sam's ready call yo who's what do you
guys think what do you guys think
actually what I put up what do you guys
think with twenty five fifty in a
Hondo's like what should I be thinking
about what are good packages I
definitely think skyping in live with no
question like if you're an incubator or
if you're like a private equity firm you
gotta like anything that's an
organization that has underneath them
we'll do it that has always been the
case with the books
I don't want to do able to pitch me
here's why people are gonna feel like I
don't want to feel obligated like people
go yeah it's gonna be a lose-lose
situation right they're gonna buy 500
pairs right no and they're gonna they're
gonna think like he's definitely gonna
you know invest and then 99.9 percent of
time I mean really you know startups a
dog piece of dog [ __ ] and then if you
like interview me all he cares about of
sneakers and I'm like no bro your
[ __ ] app sucks dick so that's not
gonna work I want something tangible
about my time is the most valuable very
soon as tickets tickets to all our
events yeah wait till they hear about
the one in Miami I next one the next
sneaker I want to do a willy wonka gonna
be one gold sneaker and whoever gets it
like dinner with me like 25 for signed
sneakers one person is like can you you
sign all 25 right then we'll make money
flipping him what about if you buy 50
pairs you get to come in here and sit
with me while I sign all 50 pairs and we
could talk about whatever it will only
take me water so both I only send one at
the events but like I would sign both
how long would it take me it would take
you 50 pairs designed balls it
you could sign for it so it's a it's a
15-minute thing especially with the
conversation you know it's a 15-minute
thing
I mean you don't set the paper to flight
here but you might be near let's see
what people are saying 50 pairs though
is a lot of bread 100 percent Eric the
[ __ ] who do you think we're doing here
with you I'm trying to help you know
like we look like it's five thousand
dollars it's like I'm trying to [ __ ]
figure out how to bring people real
values not in one of these like I
basically want one of the things to feel
like for free that's always why these
things have always worked with my books
like somebody's like yo I paid five
thousand dollars to like high five you
know like I keep up if Randy Macho Man
Savage was still alive I paid fifty
thousand bucks to hang with him for 15
you know so then I'd be like yo all
these Randy Savage sneakers are free and
I'll flip on you know this I'll tell you
what the 50 speakers and I sign them and
you can't be a dick once I'm done you
gotta like leave my office kind of thing
is a real home run cuz you're gonna sell
for a buck 50 a pop there sighs yeah you
get everybody we get 40,000 emails a day
can I have time with you know 240
thousand so you gotta boo a Q&A session
in the askgaryvee show you know we
should do 25 50 100 and then we should
have like like five like random things
that are a thousand which is what 10,000
bucks
100,000 right here I mean the emails I
getting like y'all give you a hundred
thousand I've dinner with you looks like
real I love the guy that did the 45
pairs for you playing yeah that's gonna
be smiling he's gonna blow me out in
FIFA - I don't play fifa gravy good
content
put together because it's funny see see
if anybody's got any good I've done that
how about a production - yes LM 150
mm-hmm Q&A session you ask me we should
50 pairs of sneakers and a deal on four
DS four DS is four DS is gonna be I'm
definitely gonna do that my guy lil
little prince we're gonna do a one-day
buy a hundred pairs which is 10,000
bucks and you get a four D for free
which means we get twenty thousand ten
thousand mm-hmm
we're definitely gonna do that what's
that 50 pairs of sneakers and they spent
filming you that's never seen you know
what you need to do we need to do
something that's called 100 100 pairs we
should do a 101 pairs where you fill in
the blank yeah didn't work last time
because everybody's like it's not smart
and they're like you know because my
brother for 101 pairs or like I I get a
job I need 50 pairs every month can you
do that I can definitely do that by 10
and rap live and Instagram now it's
gonna be twenty five fifty and a hundred
because tens we're gonna do in social
media let me buy 200 pairs let's go see
Wayne oh come see me anybody who's in
for 25 50 or 100 pairs you can email me
at Gary at vaynermedia comm with
anything that's logical I'll do 50 pairs
for 15 minutes plus my Twitter handle 50
Peter's for 15 minutes what are we doing
for 50 minutes 15 50 pairs and he wants
me to shout out his Twitter handle ah
you know what people are really in my
opinion for everybody's watching people
not smart about how valuable shout out
is that's why I think the switching is
yeah but I know not that like I don't
know actually you're right it is bad
what's a cosign you can do so much with
it you know be refreshed out there
forever 50 pairs I sign you get to hang
with me and I tweet out like yo at
Charles face 47 thanks for coming
through and we take a picture with the
50 things they get like a couple hundred
Twitter followers they can take it and
use it as an Instagram ad I just don't
you know what can you get the whole team
organized
Monday and have me sign 50 pairs while I
talk to Andy about business I want to
time it time is two best the applause I
can't [ __ ] around right all right let's
see what else we got I got up in a
meeting
[Music]
young baby Tate your mother Pitters
hundred pairs is $10,000 no maybe the
hundred pairs should be the [ __ ]
15-minute thing it's [ __ ] worth it
you get to talk to me while I sign them
all and you get a tweet that's [ __ ]
worth it I don't want to do that I want
to [ __ ] just like get our [ __ ]
stream long [ __ ] I don't need time no
that's gonna be a one-off 40s but that's
those ones the people that we're gonna
email everybody and text everybody we're
gonna tell them it's gonna go live at
nine o'clock somewhere and whoever gets
them gets them like because it's too
valuable you get a four DS which is
worth 10 G's everybody's buying them and
making money and you're getting 20 G's
and these people were smart they're
literally gonna take those hundred
papers and flip them somewhere and get
50 to 70 K back I mean five to
seven-year-olds
oh [ __ ] bail tens are finished no but
these people are not bite they don't
even pay for themselves they're gonna
flip in and slip it but 15 minutes not
make it 20 my god I'm trying to make it
ten yeah chili by the way anybody here
who wants 15 minutes of my time which
goes for a lot of money it's like and
you buy a hundred pairs on case West
calm right now an email me in the
receipt you're locked in I'll see you in
New York
ASA Lindsey Rhonda who I love with all
my heart to see you my coat my cocielo
what's going on here
4d search at vaynermedia four DS
googling a lot of people are in a chat
like what's this just Google baby Google
young baby tape follow her the pender
for a reason what's up 107 T 3 Jelani
one minute is all I need Nick Walt
he's a minute could do 25 pairs 25 pairs
is 2,500 we could do 25 pair of
five-minute speed dating day we're just
you know I got it I got it
no I got it we can do 25 pairs you get
five minutes with me five minutes
there's a buzzer we do a whole thing
right you can like pitch me we can take
a photo but you also get the hang will
do it like 7:00 p.m. we'll go into 3:00
in the morning if I have to you get to
hang right here with us
twitch studio going music going I'll get
three or four influencers to its 25
Peters to be part of the party to be the
that's it
25 will get food will give a gift bag
they'll [ __ ] rock their face off will
get some live in addition twitch studios
going
you can put your twitch thing on I'll
bring one or two twitch monsters yeah
let's give it a deal what don't be no
50-100 pair should be the 1525 let's do
a part it's 200 it's 2500 is a good deal
right plaint like you give a hand for
four hours network like if you're smart
if you're smart business woman you know
that your comment cool you get five
minutes to leverage the selfie with me
in you guys know in five minutes I could
change the whole [ __ ] game you you go
play to what you meet other people
they'll be four to five others Instagram
celebrities whatever we can even put
like people in each room and do little
and you know what else the best parts
could be the network you're right it
probably isn't 5,000 our ticket what
we're gonna have some like a rapper an
athlete you could probably put a [ __ ]
influencer or business like something in
each [ __ ] conference room that's a
good idea
you see if they like it what do you guys
think about that
somebody said sound stuff I wonder if
they have time speed dating what's up
it's not you
I don't do anything guys real quick if
you want to make 2500 bucks to get the
25 pairs go to Craigslist free right now
pick up [ __ ] flip it on Facebook
marketplace the number one way to make
2500 bucks
in a heartbeat it's hard work but it's a
heartbeat is go to [ __ ] Craigslist
right now go to the for sale click in
the for sale section there's a section
called free click look at all the stuff
see what people are giving away bicycles
cabinets televisions get your [ __ ]
truck get your car get your bicycle I
don't know how you roll go pick it up
post it on Facebook marketplace Facebook
marketplace and make [ __ ] 40 bucks
here 60 bucks here
80 bucks here's 60 bucks here forty
bucks here and then 30 days you got 2500
it's a big idea
ya know it's a good idea right yeah okay
so that's definitely we're gonna do
we're gonna definitely definitely
definitely do the speed-dating part
we're gonna call it the [ __ ] party
the 25-pair party or at a 50 pair party
it's probably 15 it's cost us money
right yeah okay so the 50 pair party you
come from 7:00 p.m. to midnight five
hours you know you can't come early
because the [ __ ] building will freak
so you have to like meet downstairs
we'll figure that out you come up I need
everybody for five minutes you can pitch
me even photo you can I can take a
picture with your [ __ ] Prada a right
you get that maybe we do a couple of
like 40s like consulting sound like
d-roc maybe [ __ ] he doesn't even have
fun let him do like a d-roc video
session like people can come in he's
just talking
we got twitch going we bring [ __ ] DJ
Clue in here look it's video
I'm coming Alex they [ __ ] up um
yeah we cap it of course we can't prefer
we don't need to sell many pairs we're
doing this board for like brand 50 pairs
times 50 people 2500 pairs it's cool it
seems like a lot for telephony pairs it
should be only bucks
I feel like it's gonna be a hundred
pairs all right guys thank you so much
for hanging us with our twenty five
fifty and a hundred sneaker idea
straight up if you want to buy twenty
five fifty and a hundred pairs of the
sneakers right now and you've been
listening and kind of understand where
we're at you can email me right now
Tyler will jump in we'll close that deal
and for some reason you buy 50 because
you want to come to the party and we
make it 25 we'll refund you back I'm not
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] anyone I'm gonna make
it better for you gonna be the first
people in the line so you want to step
up and I want to dismantle case was his
website right now with like a September
24 it's gonna be the date it's September
24 lock it in just block it right now
September 24 it's gonna be the date see
ya